who is the victim the man brought down
by bullying claims or the civil servants
who an independent report says he
intimidated I think now we've seen the
report it's a variable blizzard of
snowflakes allies of Dominic Rapp have
told Sky News Richie sunac was wrong to
lose him I think he made a mistake yes
and it's the Civil Service which must
change I think the civil service is not
working in the way that it should and we
need to go back to having a civil
service that delivers for the government
of the day and this may need fundamental
civil service reform to have more
political appointees I think the idea
that the Civil Service just mutually
implements the policy of the government
of the day is no longer true but of
eight complaints against Dominic Raab
two were upheld with evidence of
aggressive conduct trust is broken down
between some civil servants and some
ministers that seems to me to be the
biggest problem here not politicization
or civil service ineffectiveness it's
that relationship of Trust on which the
top of British government depends has
broken down and ministers and civil
servants have been leaking to the media
have been reporting private
conversations have been briefing against
each other and that doesn't seem to need
to be conducive to good government labor
argue the Prime Minister must take some
of the blame he said when he came into
Downing Street he would lead a
government of integrity and he's failed
on his own terms he should have sacked
Dominic Rob in fact I'd go further he
knew the allegations he knew uh what was
being said about Mr Rob he probably
shouldn't have appointed him as Deputy
Prime Minister in the first place
Dominic Robb is now heading back to the
back benches and he won't even commit to
standing as an MP at the next election
Joe Pike Sky News Westminster